the color if IEP books okay what am i
priest talking about gender equality
yeah yeah what's link and I have to
laugh how can we meet not as equal we're
like like women are like Apple but
people are earth and yes they should
have biblical city birth that means all
day every day will pay every way okay
we're really okay oh my gosh
no just beat boxes and stick beasts
where to find them you know I'm
drastically changing the narrative okay
you can't go in and oh my gosh I love
watching this keep flowing holy cow this
is such a meme thank you this is the
beatbox dream team right now and no one
ever wants me to do that ever go to be
gender of course